If you want to hear how a trap that never
came to fruition in a previous Saw movie makes
an appearance in Spiral, then stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
This is the first time we've ever gotten a
big establishing shot of the city, and it
looks like New York.
Previous Saw films took place in a state called
The Fairweather State and the city name is
always just "Metropolitan", we never hear
the actual city name.
There are definitely parts that look like
New York in the past, but it's hard to say
if that means the whole series takes place
there, or if this is simply a case of New
York playing the part of the fictional city.
Another possibility is that this doesn't take
place in the same city as the other 8 films.
If the new Jigsaw is someone who was inspired
by John Kramer, we could be anywhere in the
country now.
The one big piece of evidence for that is
the fact that subway systems seem to be a
big part of the story here, possibly even
one of the traps involves the subway.
That reminds me of the trap we see in Jill
Tuck's dream in Saw 7, which involves a device
on a rail system, and interestingly enough,
has a Spiral thing going on.
This obviously was never a real trap, but
Jill, who if you don't remember was John Kramer's
ex wife, had to get the idea from somewhere,
maybe this was an idea for a trap that John
never used and is being brought back by this
new killer.
The movie is called Spiral, which is obviously
a reference to the pattern that shows up many
times throughout the Saw films, most notably
on Billy the Puppet.
I wonder if we learn more about the thematic
meaning behind it.
All of the images associated with Jigsaw were
chosen for a reason, and I'm guessing this
is no different.
Just look at the spiral staircase in this
shot and the Spirals that cover the traps
across the trailer.
Perhaps the reason for the Spiral symbol is
that it represents the religious aspect of
Jigsaw's following.
John's work has always been kind of cult-like.
He wears a robe and passes his teachings down
to his disciples.
The spiral symbol has a great contrast to
the symbols of popular religious icons, like
the cross, with its rigid, perpendicular edges.
We see a Christian church appear in the trailer.
The full title is Spiral: From The Book of
Saw.
Maybe the "book" is essentially a bible meant
to pass down the teachings of John Kramer.
In fact, at the beginning of the trailer,
the character Detective Banks seems to be
imparting Jigsaw's code onto his partner,
whether it is intentionally or not.
John's motto was "cherish your life", and
here's what Banks has to say about his partner's
relationship with his wife and son.
"...Emma, this is my son Charlie."
"Enjoy it while it lasts."
Kind of a weird thing to say.
And I'm not saying that he's Jigsaw, mostly
just because that would be way too obvious.
In the shot where a light is shined on this
figure underground, I noticed that the suspect
isn't actually moving, and that leads me to
believe that it could be a mannequin.
You may remember John's original workshop
was located in a mannequin factory.
Also, take a look at the shadow.
Based on the angle of the light, it should
be a long shadow, but it's not.
Meaning that this part must be a mural, which
may or may not be part of a trap.
"It's a trap!"
You would love this franchise Admiral.
Later in the trailer you can see a SWAT guy
cutting something with a buzzsaw.
I think it would be really cool if the new
villain named himself Buzzsaw.
Also, it' looks like he's cutting away one
of those secret doors, like we saw in Gideon
Meatpacking Plant in Saw 5.
The trap we do see just before the title card
hits looks to be a new take on an old classic,
the good old reverse bear trap, only it looks
like the technology has been updated for 2020;
this one looks to be a hand-free version.
It does look as if this movie is pretty removed
from the last two entries, Saw 7 and Jigsaw.
Here's something interesting to note.
The seven Saw films all share a common look.
The color schemes are similar and they use
the same aspect ratio.
Spiral seems to have a similar aspect ratio
and look to the 2017 sequel Jigsaw, but as
far as we know, there are no Jigsaw characters
in Spiral.
All we know about the killer here is that
he's going after cops,
"They're targeting cops."
That could suggest that it's Logan Nelson,
from Jigsaw, whose goal was to get revenge
on the corrupt cop who was responsible for
letting his wife's killer go free... but again...
it seems too obvious.
It feels as if this movie is setting up a
new Jigsaw successor, and maybe Spiral, is
part of a new trilogy or tetralogy, where
each movie introduces us to a new successor,
and in the final movie they end up battling
it out... or teaming up to make the ultimate
team of villains.
That's just an idea though, whatever happens
I'll be covering everything Saw here on the
channel.
Starting in March I'm going to be doing Things
You Missed episodes for all the Saw movies
including Spiral, and Horror History episodes
on all your favorite Saw characters, so let
me know who you'd like to see me cover in
the comments, and also these shirts will be
available in the merch store soon, so make
sure you don't miss out on any of that content
by subscribing to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.